Alhamdulillah.
[Silence]
forbdal.
forch.
[Silence]
mentions
the next narration in his book
in the chapter regarding sincerity
and intentions. S he says on the
authority of Abbass.
So he is the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam's
paternal cousin. His cousin from his
father's side.
Abdullahb
was one of the most knowledgeable
scholars amongst the companions of the
prophet sallall.aii alaihi wasallam and
he is one of the most prolific narrators
of hadith.
He narrates that the messenger of Allah
said in his
narrating
to the companions of what Allah himself
said.
So this is what is referred to asiith.
He says indeed Allah most high
has written and determined
the good and bad deeds, the merits and
the sins. We say
is a merit or a good deed
is a sin or a bad deed that Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala has written these
meaning that he has determined and he
subhanahu wa ta'ala has made it that
his judgment of his creation his
judgment of the human being his judgment
of the followers of the prophet Muhammad
Muhammad sallall.aii wasallam that he
will judge their good deeds and bad
deeds in the following way.
He said, "Hence, whoever
intends on doing a good deed and then
does not end up doing it, Allah will
write it for him and count it as a full
merit, a full hass." Notice the wording
here is hem. Hem. Hem here in this
context doesn't just mean that it's a
fleeting thought or a distant desire
or a distant intention. Alhem is the
stage that a person reaches in his
intention just before he goes to do
something. So it is a strong intention.
It's an intention
that is complete and it is the stage
just before a person goes and does
something. So what is meant here by a
person intending to do a good deed is
not just that you know I wish I could do
this or it'd be nice to do this or
you know maybe I'll do this. No, it is
I'm going to do this following thing.
Maybe even a plan, maybe even
preliminary steps in doing that thing.
But then the person doesn't end up doing
it for whatever reason. It could be for
any reason. It could be because let's
say a person has the intention to wake
up and make
and then the person goes to sleep and
sleeps through the night. They didn't
wake up. They didn't make it
or a person has the intention to go to
the masid and then they get sidetracked
by something or they forget or what have
you. These here are instances when a
person does not do something or even
intentionally leaving it off. So for
instance, a person says to himself he's
going to go to the masid and then
decides against it. But he had this
strong intention to do it. Even if it is
laziness, even if it is you know a
lack of enthusiasm, if the person had
the intention to do it, the strong
intention and the will to do it and does
not end up doing it for whatever reason,
it is counted as a full merit with
Allah. And this is from the incredible
generosity of Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala.
He says, "And if he intends to do
something, a good deed, and then does
it, Allah will write it with him
as and count it as 10 good deeds
up to 700 merits up to many more merits
beyond that. So you've got 10 up to 700
in some wordings of the narration 10 to
70 to 700 up to many more beyond that.
What is meant by that from 10 to 700? It
depends on the other factors that are
taken into consideration
when any deed is judged by Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala. Two people come to
make salah. They make the exact same
salah but their reward is very different
than each other with Allah. One is
clearheaded, concentrated,
focused in his prayer. His heart is more
alike with passion. This person's
reward is going to be very and
drastically different than a person who
is reluctantly making the same salah.
Even though outwardly if we were to
quantify
these two prayers they are in quantity
exactly the same. However, in quality
in actual substance they are very
different. And so here the prophet
sallallah.aii wasallam says
he will write it as 10 merits up to 700
merits up to many more merits beyond
that.
And again this has to do with the
quality and the strength of a
person's intention and sincerity and so
forth. the factors that go into
judgment.
And what we understand from this is that
any good deed that is actually done,
no matter how reluctantly it's done, any
good deed that is actually done and
followed through with will never be
written as less than 10 times.
Never be written as less than 10 times.
He says,
"And whoever intends to do a bad thing,
a bad deed, a sin, commit a sin, and
then does not do it, Allah most high
will write it for him as a full merit."
This is of course with the condition
that he leaves it off for the sake of
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala.
In the narration of im Muslim of this
same narration Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
says
he says because he has only left this
sin for my sake. So a person in order to
have a good deed written for them in
place of an intention that was bad that
he left off,
it has to be that he leaves it off for
the sake of Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala.
He says, "And if he intends
to commit a sin and then ends up
committing that sin, Allah writes it as
one sin."
Now, this is different than the
writing of good deeds. Good deeds will
be written at least 10 times. So every
one deed a person does it's as if he has
done it 10 times.
However, sins are only written once.
They're only written as one sin.
However,
sins are never multiplied in that sense.
But they may be magnified.
What does that mean magnified?
Well, let's say a person commits that
same sin in Mecca, for instance. Let's
say that person commits that same sin in
any masjid. Let's say that person
commits that same sin during a holy time
during the sacred months. Let's say that
person commits that same sin against a
righteous or
u a righteous person or a scholar of
Islam etc. Then this sin while written
as one may be
magnified because it becomes more grave
depending on the circumstances.
This narration has been collected by
both and Muslim.
Alhamdulillah.